d d
les gens se prennent jamais la pâte on
n'a pas sur ce passif hâte que ça les
gens se battent mais jamais ne se tapent
pour voir ce qu'il y a en de ça
les gens restent à surface bien certain
que rien ne surpasse les gens s'efface
quand ils se font face trop inquiet
qu'on les surclasse les gens des gens
des gens des gens les gens les gens
sains
leurs jambes à leur cou les gens ont
l'air fou genre tombé dans le flou
les gens se vante d'être gentil se voit
comme des gants dit même quand ils sont
en dit tout on en dit tout sur les gens
disent temps tels des anges quand je
pense que les gens c'est nous vient
envie de me taire sur les gens mais vers
doucement je perds on a beau dire mais
les ovales coup je parle des gens tu
parles des gens ils parlent des gens
mais les gens c'est nous nous parlons
des gens vous parler des gens on parle
des gens mais les gens c'est nous je tu
ils nous vous ne s'avoue pas que les
gens c'est nous les laissons dire du mal
de nous les gens à propos des gens
geignent il serait temps qu'on daigne
faire les pas pour panser nos plaies qui
saigne